DAVID MALAN: Hello, world.
My name is David Malan, and this is
CS50, Harvard University's introduction
to the intellectual
enterprises of computer science
and the art of programming for
majors and non-majors alike.
Indeed, whether you're among
those less comfortable or more
comfortable with technology, this
course, and computer science more
generally, are in fact for you.
And it is free via platforms like
edX, YouTube, Apple TV, Google TV,
and CS50's own website.
Through this course, you'll learn
how to think more methodically, more
algorithmically, so to speak.
You'll learn how to
communicate succinctly
and precisely, and you'll learn how to
solve problems efficiently with code.
Indeed, this course begins
at the very beginning
with a very friendly graphical
programming language called Scratch,
via which you'll write code
by dragging and dropping
puzzle pieces that
only interlock together
if it makes logical sense to do so.
We'll then transition to C, a more
traditional keyboard-based language,
via which you'll learn how computers
work underneath the hood, so to speak.
Thereafter, the course
moves on to Python,
a more modern language via which you can
analyze data, automate processes, build
web applications, and more, and SQL,
via which you can read and write
lots and lots of data in databases.
Toward course's end, we'll dive
into HTML, CSS, and JavaScript,
languages with which you can create
web apps and mobile apps alike.
And at course's end, you'll design and
implement your very own final project
for the world to see.
You will have learned how to program.
And if at any point
you get stuck, there's
a whole CS50 community to support you,
as well as nowadays a virtual rubber
duck of whom you can also ask
questions anytime, thanks to AI.
All this and more, this is CS50.